franziska ferber wollte schon immer
sehnlichst kinder aber es klappte nie
sie versuchte wie so viele alles was in
deutschland an reproduktionsmedizin
legal ist die starke hormonbehandlung
führte zu ohnmachtsanfällen mit schweren
stürzen doch selbst das konnte sie nicht
aufhalten mit einer eizellspende hätte
sie vermutlich schwanger werden können
weil die aber in deutschland verboten
ist hätte sie dafür ins ausland gehen
müssen strafbar ist das nicht aber ihr
gewissen plagte sie aber jeder der nicht
spontan normal wie man dass er so schön
sagen würde schwanger wird muss sich mit
ethischen fragen auseinandersetzen weil
ich glaube am ende vom tag ist das was
zählt dass man sich im spiegel in die
augen schauen kann
was technisch längst möglich ist ist
ethisch höchst umstritten in vielen
westlichen ländern ist die als spende
und in einigen auch die leihmutterschaft
erlaubt in deutschland ist beides
verboten
hier dürfen nur normale künstliche
befruchtungen durchgeführt werden
heribert kentenich leitet 1 von 131
kinderwunschzentren in deutschland vor
mehr als 40 jahren wurde das erste baby
im reagenzglas gezeugt seitdem haben
sich die technischen möglichkeiten
rasant weiterentwickelt vieles davon ist
hier verboten
standard ist heute die künstliche
befruchtung 110.000 behandlungen werden
jährlich durchgeführt in deutschland
erlaubt ist auch die samenspende sie ist
seit 2018 gesetzlich geregelt in
deutschland verboten ist die
eizellspende dabei wird das ei einer
anderen frau mit dem samen des mannes
künstlich befruchtet und der wunsch
mutter eingepflanzt
ebenfalls verboten die leihmutterschaft
dabei trägt eine fremde frau das kind
aus ihr wird das mit dem samen des
mannes befruchtete ei der wunsch mutter
oder einer spenderin eingepflanzt um
diese verbote gibt es seit jahren
heftige diskussionen
die bundesregierung hat vor zwei jahren
das verbot der eizellspende bekräftigt
viele tausend frauen mit kinderwunsch
ließen sich durch gesetze nicht
aufhalten und gingen jedes jahr ins
ausland längst floriert dort ein
milliarden-geschäft schwanger oder auch
nicht das ist eine vermischung von
kommerziellen interessen
in deutschland gibt es seit einigen
jahren sogar messen zum thema die
kinderwunsch tage hier im frühjahr 2020
in köln vor dem ersten corona shutdown
obwohl vieles davon in deutschland
verboten ist dürfen ausländische
kliniken dennoch dafür werben eine
gesetzeslücke weil die privatsphäre der
besucherinnen und besucher geschützt
werden soll dürfen wir nur außerhalb der
öffnungszeiten filmen geworben wird auch
für die leihmutterschaft beliebt bei
deutschen paaren die sich das leisten
können sind kliniken in den usa kosten
für eine leihmutter ab 130.000 euro
aufwärts geradezu günstig dagegen
kliniken in der ukraine
sie bieten ein baby paket schon ab
64.000 euro an teilweise sogar mit baby
garantie schlagzeilen machte diese
praxis vergangenes frühjahr durch den
corona shutdown konnten rund 100
neugeborene in kiew nicht abgeholt
werden
die bilder der babys gingen um die welt
veröffentlicht von der klinik selbst um
politischen druck auszuüben
kurz darauf durften die eltern aus dem
ausland die babys abholen
der fall löste weltweit eine heftige
diskussion über die ethischen fragen der
leihmutterschaft aus was in deutschland
verboten ist erlauben einige andere
länder der eu
doch nur wenn die leihmütter aus reiner
nächstenliebe handeln etwa
großbritannien österreich dänemark
griechenland ist das einzige land der eu
in dem auch ausländische paare eine
leihmutter in anspruch nehmen dürfen
ich fliege nach griechenland jedes jahr
werden dort rund 200 leihmutterschaften
vorgenommen das land erlaubt sofern sie
rein altruistisch sind in der
wirtschaftskrise erkannte man den
medizin tourismus als wirtschaftsfaktor
und gründete sogar einen rat für
medizintourismus 2013 wurde die
leihmutterschaft auch für ausländer
erlaubt seitdem kommen paare aus aller
welt hierher
wie es leihmüttern geht die für
ausländische paare kinder bekommen wurde
bislang allerdings nicht untersucht
kontakte können wir nicht einmal
experten vermitteln
schließlich gelingt es mir doch noch
eine junge frau zu finden
die leihmutter werden will sie will
nicht gefilmt werden ich treffe sie mit
einer übersetzerin eine klinik bot ihr
an leihmutter zu werden wenn ihr
jüngstes kind etwas älter ist sie ist
alleinerziehend mit drei kindern und
betont immer wieder dass es ihr nur ums
helfen gehe das gesundheitliche risiko
blendet sie aus
gott sieht uns und wenn du gute dinge
tust kommen diese vielleicht schon am
nächsten tag zu dir zurück
einen job hat sie derzeit nicht sie lebt
mit ihren drei kindern von staatlichem
kindergeld monatlich 280 euro offiziell
dürfen leihmütter bis zu 10.000 euro
aufwandsentschädigung erhalten
es gehe aber auch um viel höhere summen
sie habe von 30.000 euro gehört es ist
ein guter start diese summe es ist ein
guter start ins leben diese 30.000 euro
30.000 euro das wäre viel geld ist das
doch das entscheidende motiv
ich fliege mit meinem
journalistenkollegen sören nach kreta
wir geben uns als kinderwunsch paar aus
mit mitte ende 40 würden wir für ein
eigenes baby alles geben griechenland
bietet wunsch eltern einen wichtigen
vorteil
vor gericht wird ihnen das kind schon
vor beginn der schwangerschaft
zugesprochen
in einer kinderwunschklinik erkundigen
wir uns nach einer leihmutter anders als
bei meiner anfrage als reporterin
bekommen wir ganz schnell einen termin
filmen können wir diesen nicht
nach einer stunde tauschen wir uns über
die eindrücke aus ein arzt und eine
assistentin erzählten uns das hier paare
aus der ganzen welt babys bekämen für
offensichtlich viel geld für uns beliefe
sich das auf 78 bis 85.000 euro
die leihmutter bekäme davon rund 20 bis
25 tausend und eine emotionale nähe
sollten wir zu der leihmutter nicht
aufbauen für diese stehe das geld im
mittelpunkt der verkauf weil sie hat ja
im prinzip sofort gesagt dass jetzt erst
das geld deswegen machen 800 bis 1000
euro pro monat die dann fällig werden
wäre ja bekommen dürfen und dann kommen
aber noch mal zehn bis fünfzehntausend
dann bei also weil auslieferung des baby
bekommen die leihmütter noch mal 10.000
euro haben uns beide gesagt also sowohl
der arzt als auch die assistenten also
so richtig altruistische wirkt das alles
nicht mehr mit den zahlen konfrontiere
ich die jura professorin katharina von
petacchi als vize-vorsitzende der
griechischen nationalen aufsicht für
reproduktionsmedizin hat sie die
dortigen gesetze damals mit verantwortet
wir haben mehrfach gehört dass die
leihmütter aus finanziellen motiven
handeln und mitunter 25 bis 30.000 euro
erhalten sollten was sagt sie dazu
das ist völlig illegal
der gesamtbetrag den sie erhalten konnte
beträgt 10000 20000 ist illegal 20.000
ist eine bezahlung eine bezahlung würde
gegen unsere moral und die menschenwürde
verstoßen
die darf nicht erlaubt werden sie steht
im widerspruch zur nichtverfügbarkeit
des menschlichen körpers
ich sage ihr dass wir als wunsch eltern
78 bis 85.000 euro bezahlen sollten
85 85 jahre 85.000 85.000 euro
das ist nicht möglich ich habe dinge von
ihnen erfahren dass es nicht möglich das
ist ein außergewöhnlicher betrag den ich
noch nie gehört habe also ich bin
wirklich schockiert ehrlich
es tut mir sehr leid dass sie ausländer
so behandeln weil wir das nicht so
gemeint haben als wir die griechischen
kliniken für den reproduktions tourismus
geöffnet haben
wir wollten nicht dass die menschen
ausbeuten katharina von qadhafi will
sich nun dafür einsetzen dass der sache
nachgegangen wird
offensichtlich haben einige kliniken aus
der leihmutterschaft ein geschäftsmodell
gemacht
ebenfalls verboten in deutschland ist
die eizellspende sie ist deutlich
günstiger als die leihmutterschaft und
wird jedes jahr von einigen tausend
deutschen paaren im ausland genutzt
anlaufstelle nummer 1 in europa ist
spanien
auch hier wird mit altruismus geworben
kliniken im ganzen land setzen jedes
jahr 24.000 gespendeten eizellen ein
tendenz steigend
doch welche folgen hat der transfer der
nur wenige minuten dauert und wer
profitiert davon
ich besuche eine kinderwunschklinik eine
der beliebtesten in deutschen
kinderwunsch poren ein österreichischer
arzt ist für deutschsprachige
patientinnen zuständig ich habe drei
erstgespräche am tag von dem ungefähr
80% dann auch die therapie anfangen dann
kommt aufs jahr gerechnet doch
ordentlich was zusammen laut spanischem
gesetz müssen als spenderinnen anonym
bleiben offiziell treffen darf ich keine
von ihnen im herzstück der klinik wird
mir erklärt wie die eizellspende
funktioniert das ist der operationssaal
wo die funktionen der patientinnen und
spenderinnen durchgeführt werden
die einzel spenderin wird durch
hormongabe so stimuliert das statt einem
mehrere produziert werden
diese werden eher mit einer operation
entnommen das ist relativ ungefährlich
doch ein risiko bleibt auch wenn sie
selten sind können sogar schwere
komplikationen auftreten wie die
verletzung innerer organe oder die
spätere unfruchtbarkeit
die klinikgruppe wirbt damit eine der
größten banken der welt zu betreiben
seit 30 jahren werden hier kein zellen
und impressionen von spenderinnen und
patientinnen aufbewahrt
sehr viele im moment kann ich ihnen
nicht die genauen zahlen nennen aber die
anzahl der embryonen die wir
gleichzeitig aufbewahren können und das
über viele jahre also das sind über
60.000 und wer sind die vielen tausend
spenderinnen jakob dieplinger meint
spenden gehöre in spanien zum leben
einfach dazu
als ich hierher kam war das schon auch
eine der ersten sachen die mich
überrascht haben es gibt tatsächlich
diese altruistisch einer spende so wie
wir zu hause in deutschland oder
österreich blutspenden gehen
der finanzielle aspekt ist natürlich
auch da je nachdem wie viel erzählen wir
bekommen ja witzig dass um die 1000 bis
1500 euro das ist jetzt nicht so viel
ja und wenn sich mal einer studentin von
der uni valencia damit ein wochenende
auf ibiza können ich persönlich habe
kein problem damit
1000 euro für viele ist das eine menge
geld und selten geht es wohl um die
finanzierung eines kurzurlaubs eine
durchschnittliche spanierin unter 26
jahren hat deutlich weniger im monat zur
verfügung fast jeder zweite junge mensch
findet keinen job wird hier nicht doch
eine finanzielle notlage ausgenutzt weil
die spenderinnen anonym bleiben sollen
vermitteln mir die kliniken keine
kontakte und öffentlich sprechen die
frauen in spanien praktisch nie darüber
schließlich habe ich doch noch erfolg
und finde eine frau die vor unserer
kamera zum ersten mal öffentlich über
ihre spenden spricht
die 30 jährige elia hatte als studentin
vor fünf jahren nicht genug geld zum
leben wie so viele junge spanierinnen
konnte sie keinen guten job finden für
jede spende bekam sie 900 euro insgesamt
spendete sie sechsmal zu dem zeitpunkt
hatte ich einen job mit sehr wenigen
stunden also mein einziges sicheres
einkommen betrug 200 euro
ich musste die miete bezahlen und das
essen als ich das erste mal spenden
gingen erinnere ich mich dass ich
bezahlt wurde und als ich nach hause kam
direkt zum vermieter ging und ihn die
miete bezahlte für die nächsten drei
monate
elia wusste was sie sagen sollte um als
spenderin angenommen zu werden
und dann sieht er mich an und sagt nun
was ist ihre motivation das zu machen
nein meine motivation ist altruistisch
um menschen zu helfen und ich dachte
ehrlich entweder bin ich eine sehr gute
schauspielerin
oder ich bin ein soziopath oder was auch
immer oder dies ist ein sehr schlechter
psychologe ich meine guckt mich einfach
mal an also alle leute die dort hingehen
lügen ihm ins gesicht und dieser kerl
akzeptiert ist seit jahren nimmt die
zahl der eizellspende rinnen in spanien
zu eine der wenigen kritischen stimmen
ist die wissenschaftlerin consuela
alvarez plaza
sie forscht schon lange zu einzelspenden
in spanien und weltweit und meint der
grund für die zunahme seien alleine
finanzielle anreize was die kliniken mit
geschickten strategien überdenken würden
die kliniken richten ihre werbung
einerseits an frauen die finanzielle
hilfe also geld brauchen
[Musik]
andererseits werden sie mit
nächstenliebe und hilfe und außerdem
bieten sie umfassende gynäkologische
untersuchungen an so dass man
schließlich sagen kann die spende sei
nicht ausschließlich aus finanziellen
gründen erfolgt auch wenn diese
vorhanden sind
ohne die würde sich niemand
handeln lassen und ja ein
offensichtliches risiko eingehen
auf der einen seite frauen in
finanzieller not auf der anderen seite
paare mit verzweifeltem kinderwunsch wie
erleben die den besuch in den kliniken
noch einmal geben wir uns als
kinderwunsch paar aus bekommen
kurzfristig termine in zwei kliniken
auch hier dürfen wir nicht filmen in
beiden kliniken versicherte man uns dass
es mit dem kinderwunsch auf diesem weg
doch noch klappen würde
die gesundheitlichen risiken für die
spenderin und mich als wunsch mutter
wurden heruntergespielt
außerdem wurde uns ein gentest empfohlen
der mögliche erbkrankheiten aufzeigen
würde eine klinik war mit besonders
günstigen angeboten
doch was davon ist wirklich notwendig
und was sagen deutsche ärzte zu den
preisen in spanien per skype frage ich
in deutschland nach griechenland ist in
zwei arbeitsgruppen der
bundesärztekammer zur
reproduktionsmedizin die preise selbst
seien gar nicht übermäßig hoch aber
sonderangebote oder unnötige
zusatzbehandlung wie der angebotene
gentest erweckten den eindruck der
geschäftemacherei medizin ist keine ware
wie jeder andere auch die man vertreibt
dass wir davon lebe das ist nicht
ungewöhnlich das ausflugsschiff ließen
sich auch nicht ungewöhnlich aber im
vordergrund steht für mich immer die
patientin und nicht mehr diesen eindruck
gewinnt machen halt aus ihrer schilder
hinzu komme dass die risiken sowohl für
mich als wunsch mutter als auch so die
spenderin verharmlost wurden
körperliche risiken sind das eine doch
wie geht es frauen die gespendet haben
langfristig mail sah ja hallo hallo wie
geht's lisa will zum ersten mal darüber
reden vor zehn jahren hat auch sie
gespendet und fühlt sich im nachhinein
von der klinik betrogen von einem risiko
habe man ihr damals nichts erzählt doch
ihr körper habe auf die übermäßige
hormongabe so stark reagiert dass es
lebensbedrohlich geworden sei das würde
beim heutigen stand der medizin so nicht
mehr passieren
dennoch würde sie niemals wieder spenden
in wahrheit spendete ich weil ich dachte
es könne für niemanden schlecht sei
sondern dass es etwas gutes für eine
andere frau sei eine die nicht schwanger
werden konnte würde meine eizellen
bekommen
darüber hinaus würde ich finanziell
profitieren da ich damals das geld
braucht es nach dem spenden habe ich
viel über das thema nachgedacht und bin
nicht mehr am gleichen punkt ich denke
nicht mehr so wie damals die spende
belastet melzer auch nach zehn jahren
noch den gedanken an ihrer biologischen
kinder versucht sie mit aller kraft zu
verdrängen
einen teil der eigenen identität
weiterzugeben ist eben doch mehr als
eine kurze operation wie nizza geht es
vielleicht vielen spenderinnen später im
leben bislang gibt es nur wenig
forschung dazu
eine der wenigen wissenschaftlerinnen
die zur eizellspende in europa forscht
ist die spanierin sarah la fuente von s
sie kritisiert dass spanische system
hare erfüllten ihren kinderwunsch
kliniken verdienten gut die
verliererinnen seien die spenderinnen
ich denke dass diese unklare situation
für frauen die ihre
produktionskapazitäten teilen nicht
funktioniert weder ist der part des
altruismus sehr klar weil sie keine
beziehung zu der familie haben dürfen
noch werden sie angemessen bezahlt und
haben keine rechte und kostet also das
ist eine sehr heuchlerische situation
deshalb sollte sich die gesellschaft
entscheiden entweder komplett
altruistisch oder fair bezahlt wenn wir
als deutsche spanische oder europäische
gesellschaft entscheiden dass es uns
nichts ausmacht eier oder fortpflanzungs
kapazitäten zu kommerzialisieren müssen
wir einen vernünftigen rahmen finden
indem wir die rechte der menschen achten
die bereit sind ihre eizellen oder ihre
produktionskapazitäten zu teilen
und dafür müssen sie ein gutes einkommen
erhalten
sie fordert eine klare entscheidung
nächstenliebe oder geld die praxis sieht
oft anders aus bei der eizellspende und
auch bei der leihmutterschaft es wird
altruismus gepredigt und geld gezahlt
risiken werden verschwiegen kinderwunsch
paaren unnötige behandlungen empfohlen
und oft werden überhöhte preise verlangt
wie wir damit in deutschland umgehen
sollen wird seit jahren diskutiert
die leopoldina der nationale rat der
wissenschaften dem auch heribert
kentenich angehört will die eizellspende
legalisieren nach der erfahrung mit über
30 jahren eizellspende sind die verboten
juristisch tätig medizinisch kaum
aufrecht zu erhalten
insofern bedauerlich dass man dieses in
deutschland nicht in geordneten bahnen
durchführen kann also weil man könnte
das gut regeln dass die paare beraten
werden dass die eizellspende beraten
wird dass es nun bestimmt das geld nur
gibt für die einzelspender das sehen
andere kritisch katrin braun gehört zu
einem netzwerk von wissenschaftlerinnen
dass sich gegen die legalisierung von
eizellspende und leihmutterschaft
engagiert es gebe gar nicht genügend
frauen die aus reiner nächstenliebe
spendeten dass altruismus argument sei
unrealistisch
das wird das einfallstor sein dann haben
wir immer noch zu wenige und dann wird
man die aufwandsentschädigung erhöhen
und ganz schnell haben sie da ein
geschäftszweig der darauf basiert dass
frauen risiken für sich ihre gesundheit
eingehen zum nutzen anderer eizellspende
und leihmutterschaft sind sie ethisch
verwerflich oder ist eine legalisierung
überfällig was unternimmt die politik um
diese fragen zu klären
das justizministerium verweist auf das
gesundheitsministerium und das wiederum
auf das memorandum dass die
bundesärztekammer zu dem thema
geschrieben hat
es sind komplexe rechtliche ethische und
gesellschaftliche aspekte zu
berücksichtigen
der koalitionsvertrag sieht weder die
erarbeitung eines
fortpflanzungsmedizingesetzes noch eine
änderung des embryonenschutzgesetzes vor
franziska ferber hat kein kind bekommen
sich das thema aber zur lebensaufgabe
gemacht sie berät heute paare mit
unerfülltem kinderwunsch
wir trauen uns an dieses thema nicht
dran und wir versuchen das zu
beantworten indem wir sagen in
deutschland ist es verboten bitte liebe
frauen oder bitte liebe paare geht ins
ausland und wir überlassen
zigtausende ihrem schicksal ohne soliden
juristischen rahmen ohne begleitung ohne
beratung die verboten ist sie überlassen
diese menschen ihrem schicksal und dann
wundern wir uns über die auswüchse
sowohl bei der leihmutterschaft als auch
bei der eizellspende reden
reproduktionsmediziner in der eu viel
von nächstenliebe leihmutter und
spenderinnen aber brauchen oft einfach
das geld die körperlichen und seelischen
folgen werden gern verschwiegen und
menschen mit kinderwunsch städten in
deutschland in einem dilemma mit dem sie
allein gelassen werden
sie brauchen endlich klarheit und
regelungen die für alle vier sind
[Musik]